c'est un peu devenu une routine
tous les lundis à travers le pays des
milliers d'allemands marche sous la
bannière de peggy da les patriotes
européens contre l'islamisation de
l'occident un mouvement d'extrême droite
lancé il ya moins d'un an mais qui gagne
en popularité
surtout depuis l'arrivée massive de
réfugiés concerns about manière je
m'inquiète de ces masses de gens qui
nous envahissent et je suis sûr que si
ça continue des drames vont se produire
ici dit il comme charlie hebdo du
terrorisme islamiste au terrorisme
l'organisatrice démarche peggy da à
munich rejette tout lien avec les néo
nazis son mouvement dit elle représente
le sentiment d'une bonne partie de la
population
sault ste
c'est du suicide pour ce pays
l'islam n'est pas une religion à mes
yeux dit elle c'est une idéologie qui va
ruiner le monde au cours des derniers
mois les crimes à caractère racistes se
sont multipliées en allemagne comme ce
foyer de demandeurs d'asile incendie au
mois d'août johnny l'allemagne a un
historique de violence d'extrême droite
dit nikolaï que mais selon cette
chercheuse qui étudie le racisme en
allemagne la tendance actuelle est
inquiétante des soldats et policiers
il y a de plus en plus de racisme
ordinaire au quotidien et les gens
expriment de plus en plus ouvertement
dit elle alors qu'il n'aurait pas osé le
faire il ya cinq ans et filles de 5 et
conseils mais plus l'extrême droite
raciste s'exprime plus elle rencontre de
l'opposition citoyenne manifestation de
peggy da s'accompagne désormais d'une
contre-manifestation
selon cette manifestante anticipé guida
il s'agit de ne pas laisser à l'extrême
droite les rues de la ville
ce sont des gens plein coeur plein de
haine qui ne connaissent rien à
l'histoire humaine dit elle de tout
temps il y a toujours eu de la migration
ce genre de manifestation si elles
demeurent pour l'instant marginales
témoigne de la profonde division que ce
site en allemagne la question de
l'immigration des divisions et donc
potentiellement des problèmes à venir
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada
et si vous voulez en apprendre encore
davantage sur cette crise je vous invite
à consulter notre dossier web très
complet à l'adresse que vous voyez à
l'écran